[Música]
llegamos al momento de la mañana de
hablar de economía para ello ya está en
el estudio jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido buena mañana de miércoles
vamos a hablar de europa porque los
precios de gas natural aumentaron
nuevamente bueno es que hay temores raúl
de una escasez global de este suministro
los futuros del gas holandés para el
primer mes que es la referencia europea
subieron un 4.5 por ciento hasta los 135
euros por megavatio/hora en amsterdam
mientras el contrato del reino unido-
para entrega en agosto cotizaba un 6,4
por ciento al alza los países europeos
buscan cómo llenar el almacenamiento con
proveedores alternativos y evitando por
supuesto comprarla rusia moscú cortó el
flujo de gas en un 60 por ciento a
través de una importante ruta a
principios de este mes argumentaron
problemas técnicos aunque anteriormente
interrumpió el suministro a varios
países de la unión europea porque exige
el pago en rublos tras las sanciones
europeas los países de ese continente
tienen otra dificultad raúl compiten la
compra del gas con asia que está
demandando mucho más suministro se
conoce también que el reino unido
considera la posibilidad de cortar los
gasoductos de interconexión con los
países europea como parte de un plan de
emergencia si la situación llegase a
empeorar ahora el objetivo de la unión
europea es llenar sus reservas en un 90%
para el primero de noviembre aunque una
interrupción de los flujos rusos
reduciría está cifra por debajo del 70%
jorge y el sentimiento económico de la
zona euro cayó en junio un poco menos de
lo esperado hay desánimo sobre todo en
los consumidores y en el sector de
minorista eso mostró la encuesta mensual
de la comisión europea
allí el sentimiento económico en los 19
países que comparten el euro bajó a
ciento
4,0 en junio desde los 105 0 de mayo
aunque no todo es negativo el
sentimiento del sector industrial mejoró
a 7,4 puntos desde los 65 de mayo y de
los servicios el mayor sector de esa
economía a 14,8 de los 14,1 el
sentimiento disminuyó en las cinco
mayores economías de la zona euro sobre
todo en los países bajos y lo que sí es
negativo sobre ses lo que vamos a hablar
a continuación porque conseguir el
hambre cero en el año 2030 era uno de
los principales objetivos de desarrollo
sostenibilidad a uno se va a lograr
bueno lo dijo la organización de las
naciones unidas para la alimentación y
la agricultura el informe de
perspectivas agrícolas 2022 2031 que es
elaborado junto con la organización para
la cooperación y el desarrollo económico
ocde revela que el objetivo de eliminar
el hambre al 2030 no se logrará si la
productividad agrícola mundial no se
incremente en un 28 por ciento eso
significa tres veces más de lo que ha
crecido en la última década para
lograrlo raúl el objetivo de las
cosechas deberían duplicarse para llegar
al 24 por ciento mientras que la
producción de carne animal tendría que
crecer un 31% los expertos ahora citan
entre los principales obstáculos para
alcanzar este objetivo de reducir el
hambre como los efectos del cambio
climático la pandemia de coronavirus y
las dificultades por la guerra en
ucrania en las cadenas de suministro hay
que tomar en cuenta que ucrania y rusia
son dos de los productores y
exportadores de cereales más importantes
del mundo con una producción conjunta
del 30 por ciento de trigo mundial del
50 del aceite de girasol y del 15 por
ciento de los fertilizantes que también
son muy importantes para la producción
agrícola de hecho la guerra está
produciendo el efecto contrario que es
una escasez de alimento en países de
asia y áfrica ahora sí jorge nos venimos
a nuestro continente en argentina los
empresarios rechazan las nuevas medidas
del banco central que limitan el acceso
a divisas para pagar las importaciones
bueno raúl la protesta vino precisamente
de parte de la cámara argentina de
comercio y servicios los empresarios
advierten de las consecuencias negativas
sobre la productividad que tendría esta
disposición y es que el banco central
adoptó esta semana medidas que endurecen
el acceso a divisas para importadores
del sector privado argumentando una
escasez de reservas monetarias y
obligando a las empresas a obtener
financiación previa para poder importar
bienes de consumo materias primas bienes
intermedios e inclusive bienes de
capital pero los empresarios se quejan
de que en argentina hay malas
condiciones financieras y crediticias
que reducen la posibilidad de que las
empresas puedan obtener financiación de
proveedores del exterior y lb inclusive
los costos según los agremiados la menor
oferta de bienes importados podría
suponer más presión en la inflación que
de hecho ya supera el 60 por ciento
en argentina cifra el día jorge para
finalizar este primer bloque económico
8500 millones de dólares es el costo por
la crisis de agua que hay en eeuu un
informe de la organización de clip
afirma que en ese país al menos 2
millones de estadounidenses no tienen
agua corriente ni un retrete que
funcione una crisis que cuesta a esa
economía 8 mil 580 millones de dólares
al año jorge como siempre gracias a por
toda la información económica pasamos a
hablar con un marisa de deportes
[Música]